do you like scary movies what's your
favorite scary movie screen for alright
so it's been 10 years since the last
screen movie it's also been 10 years
since Neve Campbell's character Sidney
Prescott has been in Woodsboro her
hometown which is where the first Scream
takes place so the time lines meet up a
decade later and it's time to recharge
this franchise and although we have the
surviving cast from the original scream
trilogy returning in this one we have a
whole slew of new faces that can reach
mobile booms certain death labyrinth
most of the cast in this movie consists
of 27 year old girls portraying
high-school students in which case god
bless you was Craven oh they're actually
high school girls portraying high school
girls in which case god bless you was
Craven and the main character in this
movie is Emma Roberts Eric Roberts
daughter which is really funny because
if you noticed that Julia Roberts is
like hotter now I can kind of see why
she has to compete with her niece I mean
that [ __ ] has got to give you a complex
now personally for me I love the
original scream it's not just a
throwback to scary movies it's a
throwback to like movies in general if
you're a movie fanatic you'll like the
first screen movie the next two screen
movies I wasn't really fun because the
first screen movie look defined things I
mean a normal guy snaps kills people and
bases it off scary movies that was
awesome that was original and we were
promised new decade new rules which I do
kind of feel like I was bait and
switched by that phrase cuz the only
time in this movie it really plays that
up is the first 10 minutes of the movie
and I really liked the first 10 minutes
it's hilarious it's awesome it's like my
favorite part the movie's supposed to
recapture that feeling that scream one
gave us you know defining a genre and
[ __ ] but it never really does it more or
less captures the feeling of the last
scream movie which is why was this movie
made is basically the same thing as the
last couple Scream movies you have a
bunch of new faces that get killed while
the whole time you're thinking who is
the killer and did I guess the killer
yeah I kind of at one point I was like
that's the killer but I also said that
to everyone on screen at one point so no
I didn't guess [ __ ] I'll say it like
this if you like the entire scream
trilogy you'll like this it's more the
same stuff you've come to love if you
like the first scream but you weren't
really a fan of scream 2 and or 3 you're
pretty much gonna like this about as
much as you like scream 2 or 3 or lack
thereof and if you didn't like any of
the scream movies why would you watch
this you're going to hate it as a fan of
scream 1 found the sequels and I will
say screw forum is okay but you're not
going to remember in t-minus the exact
you leave the movie theater it's like
cinema hypnosis while you're in the
movie theater you're like I'm having a
good time with this movie for what it is
then you leave the movie theater it's
like you're broken from a spell you're
like I remember liking that movie five
seconds ago but it's really not that
good weird it's funny that this movie
makes fun of franchises that just milk
it forever and now it's a franchise that
milks it forever and what happened to
Dewey's limp in the last couple screen
movies do we had a limp because you know
a knife severed a nerve he's all walking
around like he had spina bifida or
something and now he's all walking
around normal like alright I have police
work to do
it's a whole stem cell thing although I
did like the end of the movie I like how
it all wrapped up it was actually pretty
cool it's like the biggest redeeming
quality of this movie everything leading
up to it is the same stuff as scream two
and three and although it never shows it
on film I know who the real killer is
based on the fact that he talks like
this when he asks you what your favorite
scary movie is it could only be me
Solid Snake you didn't see that one
coming did ya cuz I'm no hero
I'm actually a killer crazy [ __ ] right
however as a collection like screams one
through four probably be a good time if
you're watching them on like Halloween
with a bunch of friends and some alcohol
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you